The sacrifices that you've made over the
years, I'm not actually sure if I can
repay you for. I'm getting upset now...
Dear mum, I love that you can spell every single word
in the dictionary when I
need to WhatsApp you and ask you how to
compose emails and letters. Dear mum,
from watching you you have taught me how
to be a badass... When I needed you, you
dropped everything. Your work, your social
life, your own relationships to be by my
side in a difficult time not only
difficult for me but for you and dad. You
raised me pretty much on your own and I
can't imagine that to be very easy.
You've taught me acceptance and not to
strive to be somebody else or search for
change in unchangeable situations. You
always made sure your kids always had,
even if it meant that you would go
without and the sacrifices that you've
made over the years I'm not actually
sure if I can repay you for even if I
tried. When I was single and alone you
were a best friend to me but more
importantly you were the ultimate
hospital buddy,
staying every night with me before surgery,
sitting with me in recovery. Sometimes I
was boring, sometimes I was depressed,
sometimes I just had nothing to talk
about because I didn't do anything with my
life but you were always there to watch
daytime telly with me and help me heal
from the inside and out.
Having to leave my daughter at hospital
after she came early literally broke my
heart in two. I blamed myself because I'm
a petite woman I kind of thought my body
just couldn't handle pregnancy and that
maybe I just wasn't ever meant to be
a mum.
I blamed myself more so just because of
like the job that I do, like, social media
and people would make me feel like it
was my own fault.
People would say things to me like I'll
be surprised if your baby survives
because your bump is so small and then
it would scare me and I really think
that my baby wouldn't make it, but it's fine, had mum.
I had you back Jayde, don't you worry. When
you said about you know the hours we
spent in hospital together, we always
tried to find the funny side of things
didn't we? We always try to make light of
what was happening because it helped
helped us both. I'm so proud of how far
you've come. Thank you.
You know you're not a selfish
person you know you give what you can
Aww, don't get upset. You're good
to me, you look after me I'm just
grateful, you'll be the daughter that
you are. You've grown so much in yourself
and I'm just so immensely proud of you.
Just keep doing what you're doing Jayde
and you will get far, don't bother with
people, what they got to say just
just do you.